let's go next to our old friend Oh
Okafor from the five one three hey are
you there uh yeah Wow thank you so much
for that shout out of course hey what's
the correct pronunciation of your first
name I know you go by oh because it may
be tough for some people to pronounce
but how do you say it um so it's
actually only some that do Okafor
so I mean small story like my parents
are actually from Nigeria but I was
actually born here right got it
very good okay ELISA Madhu ah I think I
got it yeah wow that was actually
perfect but yeah I just wanted to talk a
little bit about the progressive
movement the past couple of weeks I've
been a little bit concerned because you
know with everything with Bernie Sanders
dropping out of the race and endorsing
Joe Biden and you know his supporters
turning on him like I do I feel like the
progressive movement at this very moment
is in disarray and I was just wondering
what your thoughts are on what's going
on right now so here's what I'm going to
lean towards in the interest of because
remember oh I want to remove Trump in
November and I think I don't want to
play a role in dividing the left
I want to unite the left as much as
possible so here's my view the world of
the Twitter reddit online left during
the primary made it seem like the Bernie
wing of the Democratic electorate was
bigger than it actually is and in the
end when it came to votes Biden got
almost three million more votes than
Bernie so far so what we learned was
some of these ideas are over-represented
if you pay too much attention to Reddit
and Twitter and the Internet my instinct
is and we're seeing it with our callers
today where we had you know a yang
supporter who's voting Bernie a
socialist who's voting Bernie I'm sorry
who's voting Biden socialist was voting
Biden and a former Bernie supporter
who's voting Biden my instinct is that
the progressive movement is not really
very divided I think that those who want
to
be loud and boisterous and say Joe's
gotta come for my vote my votes not a
blank check
I don't know anybody any oh you know all
this stuff I think they're being way
later online than they actually are in
the electorate I think most Bernie
supporters probably ninety percent
eighty eight to ninety percent are going
to vote for Biden the question is will
the ten percent that don't flip the
election I don't know the answer
gotcha oh yeah that's pretty much all I
had and the last thing I wanted to say
is that I was a Bernie Warren died and I
am 100% onboard with Noam Chomsky and
Bernie Sanders that we must go for Joe
Biden and that we must defeat Donald
Trump as well all right there we go
Elysa med dua Okafor I hope I got that
correct
really appreciate your call you did
great have a great one
all right take care great to hear from